what up guys
uh this is our first day on the
spider-man no way home press tour
we're about to watch the new trailer
which comes out soon
i'm pretty excited interesting
all right we ready yeah let's go i'm
quite nervous actually
[Music]
i've only had one week were you really
in times square where am i like yeah
we on that bridge
how difficult that bridge was to land
when i kept planning you landed in my
lap
watch that cell we wanted everyone
suit your suit was crazy in that one
i love this one
it's gonna be so sick people are gonna
lose their minds hello whoa
oh
when we did that i just was running
out of time
[Laughter]
loved it i love it
it's christmas over flying i'm not
headed for his darkness hmm well i
didn't do oh my gosh
what do you mean because it's always a
summer movie it's always come out in
june right right
get it oh
[Applause]
yummy
don't serious yeah me too nice
yeah oh now you guys almost felt that
one yeah that looked like it hurt
it did it was
whoa
oh
that was so adorbs
where's the this is all my fault i can't
save everyone yes you can you can say
that
bro do it my god
people are gonna go crazy when they see
that bit oh my goodness what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
oh my goodness people are not ready this
is a very this is that's stressful
honestly like it's i got scared i know
you guys are alive
high stakes high stakes literally well
guys that was the trailer for spider-man
nowhere home it comes out
it's really soon
like it comes out in a few days oh comes
out tomorrow
it comes out tomorrow so this will
probably come out after that yeah so you
could release this first yeah
first look
it's just us all right
that was fun yeah
you